[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe frank isola knows
you know he can understand this better
than i can frank's been covering the nba
for a long time he's of course espn's
around the horn and pardon the
interruption contributor
siriusxm nba radio the show is the
starting lineup and he is your host
where do you stand with the brooklyn
nets this year uh frank
by the way you remember the player world
be free who was from canarsie brooklyn
uh they say now that kyrie's nickname is
world b flat
i think that's a that's that's a
terrific nickname for him
the nets look really good and you know
if you go back to the bubble list
everybody says well you know the nets
all right so they made the playoffs they
were going to get knocked out in the
first round which they did
but what last year meant for the
development of guys like karis levert
obviously jared allen joe harris and now
you add
kyrie irving healthy but more
importantly kevin durant you know how
this works dan you haven't we haven't
seen durant what was it 560 days
and it's not that you forgot that he's a
great player but when you see him out
there and you're thinking man
when this guy is right it's really
lebron and then kevin durant maybe some
people think that kevin durant is a
better player certainly a terrific
offensive player if he's going to play
like this and he's going to stay healthy
the nets will be a tough team to beat
four to seven times in the playoffs
i feel a little bit i'm a little bit
more encouraged because you have kevin
durant
there because when kyrie went to boston
we said the same thing about
the celtics boy they grew up in the
playoffs now you put kyrie in there well
kyrie didn't help them get any better
and you know they were happy to see him
leave i think having durant
there almost as a sounding board or he
can whisper in his
ear hey let's get back you know it's you
and me here together we gotta
wait because they can make something
great happen here i just think it's a
really
delicate mix of either really good or
really bad here frank
yeah i i think you're right and that's
why after one game it doesn't really
matter what guy's saying
you know we're all just like the first
weekend of the nfl season we always
overreact to that first game
we're going to do that with the nets
against the warriors team but still
trying to figure things out
but you know when kyrie was in cleveland
he had lebron so you're playing with you
know arguably the greatest player of all
time so you're the number two guy there
that was perfect for him in boston they
needed him to be
the number one guy and i think he
struggled with that now with kevin
durant
you know durant when he was on golden
state he's surrounded by klay thompson
steph curry draymond green they were
okay with him being the guy as long as
kyrie irving
is okay being that so-called robin to
batman it'll work out because we know
this from kevin durant
he's good with an ensemble cast he
announced all the cast in oklahoma city
where he was the number one guy
they go to the finals obviously what
they did in golden state was tremendous
think about this
kevin durant played ten finals games
with the golden state warriors
they were nine and one in those games
that's how good kevin durant is so
i think and what i love about durant you
listen to him now except for
when charles barkley asked him a
question last night he wanted no part of
that which was pretty funny
but for the most part durant has been
very upbeat his mood seems to change i
think now that he's playing basketball
again
i think he wants to get back to that
level not only is a great player but as
a champion i think he's shooting for
what lebron did last season
i just love his attitude he seems like
he has the joy back in playing
basketball
convince me the clippers could be better
this year
by what they did in the off season i
mean
you know luke canardo got crazy money
he's a good playmaker sergey baca who
disappeared for a couple of years and
then the last two or three years with
toronto has been nothing short of
outstanding so i think he'll help and
you could have said frank you could have
said
no i can't convince you that you're
gonna i was killed
i i would give you that out well it's
funny right so charles barkley
interviews
he had a great question for paul george
last night when he asked him about
getting preferential treatment let's
face it in every line of work
the stars get preferential treatment
your crew talks about it all the time
you can treat it differently than
everybody because you're the big star we
know how it works
absolutely but you know when he brought
up the fact
because paul george admitted he said
well you know i know what it takes so
yeah sure
that's how it works but the guys who had
an issue with that that's no longer a
problem to me he was clearly referring
to mantras harold who's no longer on the
team
there were chemistry issues they didn't
want to be in the bubble last year and i
think lou williams proved that when he
went to magic city
just to get the wings as you know that's
all he was there for with some wings
so there were chemistry issues they need
kawhi to play at a different level if
lebron
had lost a 3-1 series lead to denver the
way that kawhi did we'd be killing
lebron
kawhi kind of got a bit of a pass last
year which he didn't deserve he needed
to play better
yeah but nobody cares about kawhi
leonard the way they care about lebron i
mean lebron is polarizing because
for a variety of reasons but i think the
bottom line is is people don't want him
infringing on michael jordan's territory
like no matter what he does nope he's
not going to get there
there's always going to be the yeah but
with lebron james
kawhi we just sort of go you know hey
kauai he's great two-way player
um he shows up in the playoffs okay okay
there's there's nothing else about him
he's not must-see tv
yeah and you're right so everybody loves
player empowerment we've talked about
this before
yeah player empowerment is great for the
player because when things go wrong
they're never blamed doc rivers got
blamed
in l.a look what james harden is pulling
right now with the houston rockets so
kawhi
leaves toronto goes to the clippers you
know they move heaven and earth to bring
in his buddy paul george so now kawhi
leonard is making demands they trade all
those assets to get paul george
look at the way that paul george played
in the bubble now to his credit he got
225 million dollar extension
he was actually failing up in this case
but nobody said to kweilyn hang on a
second
you're the one that made us go out and
get paul george he didn't show up on
those last three games against denver
you weren't very good
in a game seven you know who will blame
let's blame doc rivers we'll ship him
out
talking to frank isola the uh sirius xm
nba radio show is called the starting
lineup he's the host he's uh obviously a
contributor to around the horn and
pardon the interruption
uh you know i watched the lakers last
night and i just
i wasn't going to read anything into it
i just wanted to see
substitutions i wanted to see you know
certain guys were you know play with
certain players
i didn't take anything away from am i am
i being naive
by not taking anything away from that
loss against the clippers
well we you know i know i put a lot into
last year's opening night when the
clippers beat them and i thought the
clippers would give them a great run and
they won the staples center championship
the problem is the lakers won
the world championship and i think you
know for the lakers
not having rondo he was huge especially
during the playoffs and even dwight
howard
you know a pivotal moment in the nba
finals was that hard foul that dwight
had on bam out of buy which knocked them
out for a game and injured him for the
rest of his years i don't really ever
remember
dwight really being that physical but he
knocked them out of bio for a loop and
we
really never saw him again the key will
be lebron james
and we know that lebron will be ready by
the end of the season
but can he stay healthy so last night
lebron rolling his ankle
we know that on december 30th he's going
to turn 36 years old so all that stuff
starts to add up but i still have a lot
of faith in him you know he's
when he's at his best he looks like he's
about 28 years old not necessarily 36 so
i'm not going to jump to conclusions on
the lakers after one game espn nba
reporter tim mcmahon
is reporting a source says the rockets
are working with nba
office officials to review video of
james harden at a strip club
if the video circulating on social media
is verified to be recent
it's a violation of the league's coveted
protocols which would put hardens
availability for tonight's opener
in jeopardy it's disgraceful
it it really is and here's the issue
that you have with hard
he's another guy i don't want chris paul
on the team bringing russell westbrook
then that falls apart
now that you know the team looks like
it's moving trending toward not being a
playoff team he says well now i want to
be traded
well hang on a second you were the one
that was making all the calls now when
you don't like things now you say that
you want to be out of here
you don't show up for practice so steven
silas finally gets a head
head coaching job after about 20 years
as an assistant and look what james
harden does with this guy if i were
stephen south i'd call it mark cuban and
say can i have my old job back
in dallas it's a lot it's a lot less
stressful being an assistant coach in
dallas
than running the houston rockets at some
point the league needs to step in james
harden if
if this turns out to be true i think he
should be suspended because dan
he's holding the organization hostage
number one
number two with all this stuff that he's
been pulling he's hurting his trade
value
which is also hurting the houston
rockets it'll eventually work out for
james harden i'm not so sure it's going
to work out for the houston rocket
one final thing and i've been on this
topic on and off for
the last couple of years we love lists
lists drive me crazy but when we put out
the top 10 basketball players of all
time
it feels like there should be a line of
demarcation that starts 1970 on
yeah because wilt to me
should be babe ruth but he's not allowed
to be babe ruth we discredit those stats
for some reason
bill russell the greatest winner in team
sports history but not one of the top 10
players
it's as far as you know stats and
everything that he did love
love what he did but he's not in there
do i leave oscar robertson
in there do i leave jerry west in there
at some point we're gonna have a top
ten list where carl malone is not in
there
larry bird might not be in there yeah
you know there's
uh wilt's not gonna be in there i like i
don't know
how you rank players because steph curry
is he going to be a top player 10 player
of all time
is is kevin durant going to be a top 10
player of all time
yeah i think we're both you got to take
people out you got to change
yeah we're becoming that guy where now
we're we have to defend larry byrd in
terms
of being a top 10 player you should get
sunny hill mr philadelphia basketball to
tell you some stories about
will chairman i mean come on at a time
when everyone was allowed to do this dan
the guy averaged 50 points
and 25 rebounds if a nba player did that
for a week
people would say you should probably
build a statue for the guys that was 50
and 25
for one season then when you go look at
michael jordan what i love about jordan
go look at the games played like to the
players even of the 80s and the 90s
it was a badge of honor to be playing 82
games a season
now if you play 82 games you look at is
you're some kind of weirdo well clearly
you have no cachet in the league because
why would you be playing all the time
the idea isn't to play all the time
but i think you're right as time goes on
we're going to forget some of these
great players and the game was different
it's now a three-point shooting game you
know touch fouls get called all the time
you know in the 80s and 90s it was all
about warfare i looked up something the
other day
where you know there was a fight between
rick mchorn and charles oakley i think
it was back in like
85 or 86 they both got fined about 2 500
bucks more horn did get
one game for the fight so you were
almost you weren't even penalized for
playing back in the day
like you are today to the league's
credit they basically legislated
fighting out of the league but it's just
so different the game's not as physical
so everyone's scoring averages are up
great to talk to you
uh merry christmas to you thanks you uh
thanks for uh contributing to the
program this entire year we appreciate
it frank
thanks dan you look great great sweater
thank you buddy frank i sold it frank
knows fashion
uh siriusxm nba radio the show is the
starting lineup he's the
host also contributes to around the horn
and pardon
the interruption